i used to work security at the
checkpoint in the calgary airport
and on two different occasions i
actually met chris and theo because they
were coming through that checkpoint and
i stopped and talked to both you guys
because the night before i was at both
of your shows now when theo came through
he walked through the metal detector and
you know your boy lit that thing up so i
had to ask theo whether or not he wanted
the body scan or a pat down
now theo he chose the pat down of course
given the pat down and lucky for him it
was me doing it so i let your man go and
it was all good but the bait club is
this when you guys go through that
airport are you picking the body scan or
a pat down gang gang buzz buzz sword
why'd you do a pat down but
he needed some intimacy first of all
what set it off in the first place was
the two straps i won over this
[ __ ] club
yeah that's why you wanted the pad you
wanted you wanted to give him something
so second of all the thing that uh i
like to pat down because i don't trust
the machinery i would rather get the
hands on
i would rather know if something's going
on or not and have somebody know than
the machine like if you secretly brought
a bomb yeah
or are you trying to get like a a ball
exam or something like what do you mean
something like that
and that's the guy i'm talking about
what if somebody put something on you
right like you somebody snuck a b or
somebody you know if a
uh what is it called somebody from
another country who's doing crime here
what is that called uh a terrorist
terrorist yeah yeah does put something
on you they snuck a blade in your jacket
or they put a thing
you want to know yeah well i want
somebody to [ __ ] help me no so if
you're on the plane here we are if
you're on the plane and all of a sudden
you notice because you went through the
[ __ ] body scan and not a pat down
that you've got a razor on you by
mistake and somebody put it there
you you do what hijacked the plane no no
you just chill with the radio i don't
know how this got here so what the [ __ ]
you need a pat down for i don't think
also human error is way way more uh
prevalent than the [ __ ]
shh
that thing but that thing what's it
doing
you want yeah you're scared it's because
you're scared it's okay if it's fear
if you think it's because of radiation
well here's another thing i will say
this that the thing is that if the
the scanner here's what the scanner
should do is give you a [ __ ] mri
you're already there it should give you
some information i told you he was
looking for some [ __ ] ghetto medical
treatment extra [ __ ] you always want
that [ __ ] it's some ghetto medical
treatment he's like can you all check
and see if i got into my
i'm gonna have to do an mri anyways yeah
at some point so roger just [ __ ] i'm
gonna get the radiation do it now yeah
you wanted extra [ __ ] and then he wants
a printout like after the thing so like
he's gonna print out so when he's
patting you down you just say and would
you feel for testicular cancer
yeah
well here's what they should do is the
the old trick is tell them something's
in your ass and they go look in there
for you bro
nice
and then they don't find anything and
you're off the hook and they're the
weirder they've been looking and yeah
okay
fair enough yeah you play by the rules
and if there's something yeah you got to
look in my ass you just told me theo
does not have medical insurance well i'm
just saying you could say i took a nap
upstairs on the second level of the
airport for an hour i woke up it feels
like something's in my ass but if you
told them that
you know how they say don't leave your
luggage yeah yeah do you have to tell
you don't leave your ass yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah always be awake always be
awake because your ass might break any
belt yeah sleep with one ass closed baby
that's my motto and that's pretty much
100 of your ass is closed
[Music]
and the sting and the wing
[Music]
you